le court terme c'est évidemment les
tempêtes et notamment la tempête Caram
qui a qui a évidemment très profondément
euh touché notre pays et notamment deux
régions qui sont la Bretagne et la
Normandie puisque euh 1,2 million de
clients ont été coupés euh jeudi 2
novembre au matin euh 700000 d'entre eux
ont été raccordés dans les 24 heures euh
et à l'heure où nous parlons 97 %
environ des clients sont raccordés sont
à nouveau reconnectés euh et évidemment
ceci est dû à une extrêmement forte
mobilisation des équipes d'enedis et de
l'ensemble de nos partenaires
industriels et à une anticipation
également de la tempête puisque des 2
jours avant la tempête nos équipes sont
montées au front je pense que c'est le
terme qui convient de d'employés avec
3400 collaborateurs d'énedis et de nos
partenaires industriels qui se sont
rendus sur les zones qui allaient être
touché pour être à pied d'œuvre au
moment où les dégâts seraient causés de
façon quasi certaine par la tempête nous
déplorons malheureusement euh la
disparition tragique d'un de nos
collaborateurs Frédéric Despo euh âgé de
46 ans technicien d'intervention
d'énédis originaire d'Och qui était venu
aider ses collègues en Bretagne et je
veux dire toute la solidarité du groupe
à sa famille euh voilà pour la tempête
euh il reste évidemment encore à ce jour
euh 40000 de nos concitoyens qui ne sont
pas euh qui ne sont pas à nouveau
reconnectés je veux dire également que
je sais que tous nos collaborateurs ne
prendront du repos que quand tout le
monde sera reconnecté